so you just strained a muscle and the
inflammation is unbearable you wish you
had something ice-cold to dull the pain
but to use an ice pack you would have
had to put it in the freezer hours ago
fortunately there's another option a
cold pack can be left at room
temperature until the moment you need it
then just snap it as instructed and
within seconds you'll feel the chill
but how can something go from room
temperature to near freezing in such a
short time the answer lies in chemistry
your cold pack contains water and a
solid compound usually ammonium nitrate
in different compartments separated by a
barrier when the barrier is broken the
solid dissolves causing what's known as
an endothermic reaction one that absorbs
heat from its surroundings to understand
how this works we need to look at the
two driving forces behind chemical
processes energetics and entropy these
determine whether a change occurs in a
system and how energy flows if it does
in chemistry energetics deals with the
attractive and repulsive forces between
particles at the molecular level this
scale is so small that there are more
water molecules in a single glass than
there are known stars in the universe
and all of these trillions of molecules
are constantly moving vibrating and
rotating at different rates we can think
of temperature as a measurement of the
average motion or kinetic energy of all
these particles with an increase in
movement meaning an increase in
temperature and vice-versa the flow of
heat in any chemical transformation
depends on the relative strength of
particle interactions in each of a
substances chemical States when
particles have a strong mutual
attractive force they move rapidly
towards one another until they get so
close that repulsive forces push them
away if the initial attraction was
strong enough the particles will keep
vibrating back and forth in this way the
stronger the attraction the faster their
movement
since heat is essentially motion when a
substance changes to a state in which
these interactions are stronger the
system heats up but our cold packs do
the opposite which means that when the
solid dissolves in the water the new
interactions of solid particles and
water molecules with each other are
weaker than the separate interactions
that existed before this makes both
types of particles slow down on average
cooling the whole solution but why would
a substance change to a state where the
interactions were weaker wouldn't the
stronger pre-existing interactions keep
the solid from dissolving this is where
entropy comes in entropy basically
describes how objects and energy are
distributed based on random motion if
you think of the air in a room there are
many different possible arrangements for
the trillions of particles that compose
it some of these will have all the
oxygen molecules in one area and all the
nitrogen molecules in another but far
more will have them mixed together which
is why air is always found in this state
now if there are strong attractive
forces between particles the probability
of some configurations can change even
to the point where the odds don't favor
certain substances mixing oil and water
not mixing is an example but in the case
of the ammonium nitrate or other
substance in your cold pack the
attractive forces are not strong enough
to change the odds and random motion
makes the particles composing the solid
separate by dissolving into the water
and never returning to their solid state
to put it simply your cold pack gets
cold
because random motion creates more
configurations where the solid and water
mix together and all of these have even
weaker particle interaction less overall
particle movement and less heat than
there was inside the unused pack so
while the disorder that can result from
entropy may have caused your injury in
the first place it's also responsible
for that comforting cold that soothes
your pain